hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
may
[ __ ] 23rd dude
may 23rd oh look at this and i'm back
i have a little i got a new mixer
i'm sitting in a chair
i'm upright i got a microphone
and i have things that i need to say
i really don't
other than i had like one of the best
[ __ ] weekends of stand-up i've had
in uh in my 30 years
of going on stage and talking about my
[ __ ] freckled [ __ ]
i got
as i've talked about my spotted ball bag
over the years
i've seen a lot of change
some of it good some of it bad and i am
here to bring back the good and if
elected
i will make this white town even wider
build the wall build the wall
[ __ ] lunatics uh why are people into
politics i don't understand it i don't
understand it why can't you just [ __ ]
shut
the [ __ ] news off
the news
do you watch the news
i watched 24 hours of news
[ __ ] brainwashed idiot um oh i wish
we were all smart like you bill yo yeah
i do too huh i do too
um
anyway i was in tampa
florida
as opposed to ohio i'm guessing there's
a tampa in ohio they have a miami ohio
why wouldn't they have a tampa or a
sarasota
lake okeechobee um and then i was down
in west palm beach both the places i
performed at were were um
ampy theaters
and the first day i get to tampa right
uh i took a red eye out there with
forrest shaw
and uh
you know
there's a red-eye the next day you
[ __ ] wake up you feel all banged up
and all of that [ __ ] it's weird you feel
like you went out boozing and you didn't
because it's a deceivingly short flight
at least it is for me because i'm used
to flying diagonally across the country
so it takes at least five
you know six hours or whatever unless
you got some psycho tailwind then you
just realize it's only four hours to
atlanta if you just go straight across
another [ __ ] half hour
and you're in uh tampa
so
anyway uh we end up landing out there
and uh
my new vice as i went out and i got a
cup of coffee and i'm [ __ ] hanging
out and it's hot as as [ __ ] hell
florida hot tropical hot
you know
vietnam
it's america's vietnam florida is
america's vietnam okay it's [ __ ] as
humid as possible the biggest bugs i've
ever seen in my [ __ ] life and i'm
just sitting there
you know i'm not gonna lie i was excited
to be in tampa because ladies and
gentlemen they are about to go
they're going to win three cups in a row
they just i just think they're going to
do it i don't know why maybe because
they won two in a row i just feel like
they're going to do it i feel like they
although
i didn't realize the edmonton oilers
also had patrick kane i mean that's a
that's a pretty formidable line but um i
just think they're gonna do it um anyway
so sitting out there you know drinking
coffee and [ __ ]
and uh
you know florida what do they call it a
sunny place for shady people
he's [ __ ] homeless people so goddamn
friendly they're driving around they
riding by on bikes they're like hey how
you doing and you know i'm a friendly
guy i'm like i'm doing good right then
you start thinking like okay now what do
i owe that guy now
you know cause he said hello to me and i
said hello back it's like prison
you go to prison if some guy offers you
some food don't don't [ __ ] accept it
because now you owe him something
and he's gonna come back for payment in
whatever form of uh i don't know what
it always involves your [ __ ] anal
cavity
[Laughter]
ah [ __ ] um anyway
um so we were sitting out there we had a
great [ __ ] time i met some people i
invited them out to the show but it was
hot as balls and i'm like oh my god this
reminds me when i used to do the comedy
connection
gig down in [ __ ] newport rhode island
in that [ __ ] tent and it would be hot
as [ __ ] hell and i would go up there
i'm professional i wear long sleeves
when i'm on stage for the most part i
just do
all right i do something about showing
your arms
it just seems like you're just wearing a
t-shirt up there what i'm what am i
doing
did i come here to [ __ ] you know
do one of those fall cleanups on your
front and backyard or am i here to be a
professional comedian for some reason i
feel like a professional comedian you
have to have long sleeves
so anyway
as luck would have it it [ __ ] rains
out
and it just cools the whole place down
there's this ridiculous breeze
and i have a brand new button-down shirt
i'm all excited
i think it's a nice color to wear on
stage
you know
i don't have a care in the [ __ ] world
i've gotten through the first edit of
this movie now it's getting easier
instead of doing six minutes a day you
can do like 12 to 15 and each time you
can [ __ ] crank a little faster
and then you add music and it's exciting
my life's getting exciting man
and then i'm [ __ ] sitting there
waiting to go on four shaw's [ __ ]
killing and i don't know what happened i
opened one of those liquid deaths
without even thinking i didn't realize
it was full full i just [ __ ] right
before i went up i just literally just
didn't even make it to my mouth i just
dumped it all over my shirt and my lap
and you know the deal when you when you
spill liquid on your lap it always lands
right at the tip of your dick so it
looks like you just pissed yourself
right so i [ __ ] up my whole shirt
i have to put on a t-shirt
and go out there not wearing long
sleeves breaking my rule
of being a professional comedian but i
got to tell you something i went out
there there was this cool breeze the
entire show
coming off the water i was joking around
i felt like i was in a [ __ ] tampon
commercial right just
just feeling fresh and invigorated and
all of that and it was uh um
it was just a great show and then the
next day
we fly down to miami
i get another cup of coffee right i
smoke a little cigar right on the
balcony and then i go for a [ __ ] walk
around the marina
it's hot as balls and i go it's florida
it's going to [ __ ] rain again it's
going to rain again and it's going to
cool off and it's going to be great and
this time i'm not spilling any water on
my shirt
well guess what everything that i said
happened except for the rain it never
happened
and it was still [ __ ] hot as [ __ ]
um
and whenever it's sticky like that i
always i always think muggy
remember that greg geraldo bit rest his
soul
having the mexican guy doing the weather
you know hot muggy
good day to cross the river remember
that i always i can't say muggy without
saying muggy
um
certain people's bits just get stuck in
your head is what i'm saying it's like a
song
um i hope that made sense anyway uh so i
go on stage and i'm now i'm wearing the
shirt that i spilled water on the night
before but it's water so it's fine
and uh i go out there and it was just
hot as [ __ ] i didn't even realize i got
off stage i looked at the back of the
shirt it looked like i helped somebody
move a three-bedroom apartment
the whole back was all [ __ ]
all wet was [ __ ] disgusting but uh
the crowd was awesome
both shows was [ __ ] awesome and it
was such a thrill i've never headlined
an amphitheater i've done stand-up in
them a couple of times
um way back in the day on on
tours with bigger acts or a whole bunch
of big acts or something like that and i
was going on like third or whatever but
i'd never gone out and headlined one and
it took me back to going to great woods
in 1986 i want to say i saw eddie murphy
on the raw tour and i saw rodney
dangerfield
with uh
uh uh jeff nelson
opening
the weather girls opened up for eddie
murphy and i saw them at great woods in
mansfield massachusetts which i now
think is called the tweeter center or
some [ __ ] like that
and uh
i it was [ __ ] amazing i was like wow
i have not been to a stand-up show or
headlined a stand-up show one of these
things ever
and this was like
this was
the venue that i when i went and saw
stand up live for the first time that
summer
um
i don't know if i made the decision to
be a comedian but it was definitely a a
moment in my life where i was like
can you imagine
getting to do that i'll tell you what
else there was i saw that same
in that same venue
one time i saw that uh what is that band
bag of carousel dude
tempted by the fruit of another
remember that's what
i saw them they opened for uh
i think fleetwood mac or something
yes it was one of the whitest crowds
you've ever seen in your life oh yeah
dude some of the i saw some of the white
shows ever i had a free ticket to
[ __ ] uh john cougar mellencamp
uh which is great because i got to see
kenny aronoff
which is why i was there i was literally
there to watch kenny aronoff
[ __ ] lay down
those grooves all night that's why i
went there and then the but anyway i i
saw that band
it's a great song too whatever that song
is
um
and whoever their drummer was it wasn't
their original drummer it was a hired
gun and this guy was [ __ ]
killing it
absolutely killing it the [ __ ] you
know both arms looked like he was he was
like doing that break dance move like
like uh whatever the [ __ ] you call that
way they pass it from one side of their
body to the other you know what i mean
doing that molar [ __ ] but it was
effortless [ __ ] effortless he had a
big smile on his face
like
just absolutely killing it i could not
stop [ __ ] watching them
so um
i saw stevie ray vaughan there
i saw a lot of [ __ ] there man so uh to
actually be able to come back and do an
amphitheater so this is my long way of
saying thank you to everybody for uh
who came out this this past weekend and
uh
you know what i'm using this whole new
[ __ ] device and i have no idea how
much time i've done now there's no timer
on this thing
bar
337.4 what the [ __ ] does that mean
all right what do you guys think i've
done here
this feels about seven or eight minutes
maybe right we'll say seven minutes
so that means i started at 7 23 so i got
to go to 8 23.
see people i'm punching a clock too
i'm punching a clock too hey i'll tell
you who isn't punching a [ __ ] clock
right now is your boston red sox
huh
everybody getting down on them oh
they're doing this they're doing that
trevor story
literally getting a bronx cheer
the man got booed
i mean the man made a lot of money and
the man was not producing and the man
was playing in boston so the guy's gonna
get boots so he got [ __ ] boob well
guess what he did this weekend
huh
[ __ ] guy this weekend hit five home
runs had 13 rbis and seven runs scored
and the boston red sox are on a
five-game winning streak
and uh i could not be happier i've been
keeping an eye on it you know i'm
missing everything because i'm out here
[ __ ] working my ass off
um
very excited about that i can't believe
how into baseball i am this year
i think it's because i went to that red
sox game early on this year
and i immediately it just you know
after the pressure of the pregame [ __ ]
was over and then i was just sitting
there eating a [ __ ] hot dog and i was
keeping score i was just like this is
[ __ ] awesome i wish i lived
back in boston and i could walk to the
park
you know and i wish they had more day
games
for old guys like me and i could just
keep score and they would just let me
smoke just i mean david ortiz has these
little [ __ ] cigars man they're called
firecrackers you got if you get them you
got to get them
the size of like dog walkers right you
just go out in the street you walk down
the street you have a couple of puffs
think about your life you have a good
time
you know you're not hurting anybody it's
a [ __ ] great thing it really is a
great thing
i don't understand what the [ __ ]
happened
you know what it was it was those
goddamn cigarette smokers
you know what i mean
smoking a cigarette is not
in a an event
it's a [ __ ] it's just it's a habit
they're animals they stand next to
[ __ ] dumpsters and [ __ ]
um i'm not gonna lie to you like
i'm addicted to cigars i mean we all
know this so i have a [ __ ] problem
too and uh
i don't know why you just can't why
can't they just you know you know they
have like one of those things they call
it the rock pile they have always had
like these little [ __ ]
i think that's in colorado they have
like these little sections where it's
like really cheap [ __ ] seats just
stick all the smokers out there and then
you just have a fan just blowing out
you know blowing it up and over
or just stick us in an enclosed thing
with a giant smoke eater or something
like
i don't know
i did realize this weekend though you
know when i and now that i've i've
gotten into like drinking coffee or
whatever what i like about it is it's
the same reason why
i like a cigar
it's a stimulant no
no i like it because
it's um
it's a very social thing or it can be a
very solid solitary thing
same thing with the cigar you can sit by
yourself and reflect
on the good and the bad you did for the
week you know it really is like you know
mentally going to church right
and a cup of coffee can be the same way
you can either be like hanging out with
people or you can just kind of sit there
by yourself
you know have a little [ __ ] moment i
get it i get why people like going out
on their back porch
i understand it now and uh now that i've
you know
i've really given into the fact that i'm
a [ __ ] old man now
um underrated
underrated
being old and enjoying it
you know i hate to tell young people
this but like the older people get the
less cool people there are
[Laughter]
you know peop things don't work out the
way people want it to work out and then
they just get bitter and they [ __ ]
you know and they just
they just i don't know and then they
just sort of settle and they don't they
don't
pick themselves pick themselves up and
get back in the race they quit
they quit
they go to [ __ ] friendlies
they pull out a coupon and get
themselves a fribble
and they sit around and talk until noon
about all the [ __ ] all the [ __ ] they cut
a dune
um
yeah there's a lot of there's a lot of
like that you know
i found that when i became a parent just
a lot of negative [ __ ]
people oh get some sleep
how old you kid oh yeah how's he acting
he's acting good oh wait wait till your
kid's my age
it's like you ever think maybe you suck
at it
maybe you suck at being a parent um
i don't know speaking of that i came
home and uh
i have like these you know weekend daddy
daughter dates that i do when i come
back from the road it's the [ __ ] best
and i actually pulled my truck out of
the garage and my son is afraid of my
truck
not afraid he likes the truck
he still calls it a car he goes dada's
car and he goes hmm
he does that right which of course just
makes me almost cry i'm like oh my he's
a [ __ ] man you're like your [ __ ]
truck right
so he loves the garage
like when i open the garage he squats
all the way down
like they do another reference to
vietnam you know they do that that
great thing that people in asia do when
rather than standing up they squat all
the way down which is [ __ ] great for
you they're finding
you know what i mean
you don't end up being that old guy with
the blanket on his legs you know who
needs help getting up
that [ __ ] blanket that becomes part
of your pants after a while right
so he squats down like that because he
wants to see all the stuff and he knows
he has to wait till the door stops and
then he runs in he's all excited so he's
always been afraid
to go into my truck
because you know it's dark in there and
[ __ ] like that so i had to be like nice
truck nice truck so he's literally
petting the outside of it and then i got
him to the point where i opened the door
he was sort of patting the side of the
seat and then today
i had it out because i was gonna you
know i would drive it on the weekends
right so i had it out
and uh he saw it
and uh he was like [ __ ] freaking out
and i brought him down there and i don't
you know i just sort of sat into the
truck with him and it was light out
and i was like hey buddy you want to go
for a ride he's like yeah i don't think
he even knew what it was
what that meant i don't know if that
word is in his his uh wheelhouse yet
and i turned the engine on and it
started up
and he just started screaming no no when
i st he looked at me he was like whoa
and then when i started moving just
creeping forward like an eighth of a
mile an hour
he [ __ ] just went like yeah
just like it almost hurt my ear how much
he was screaming he was so friggin
excited
and uh yeah so i just kept driving him
to the end of the driveway and then i
would back up and just drive the other
driveway and he absolutely loved it and
the only way i could get him out of my
truck was i had to bribe him
with a cookie
that's the only thing that gets him when
he gets when he gets [ __ ] locked in
and he wants to do some [ __ ] he's a real
like
smart kid strong-minded kid and when he
gets locked in
and he wants to do something the only
there's only one way out paola in the
form of a cookie right so i go okay
buddy we have to we have to go out you
know his new thing he goes no way
and it makes me laugh every time and he
sees me laughing so now he takes me even
less seriously
so i have to like i just have to go like
you know
i gotta go payola
so i go come on buddy come on we have to
go it's almost dinner time you know i
got to put the truck away okay we got to
get out of the truck he's like no way
and i finally just go uh
i go you want a cookie he just turns his
head at me he goes yeah
bye bye car buy my car and the whole
thing's over
it's all you got to do
you know
i don't know how do vegans do it
i don't get how they do it you know
those people that you know those people
that like they care so much about their
kids they [ __ ] them up
feed them like seaweed and all of that
[ __ ] you know at some point you know you
got to give your kid a hot dog i guess
you
don't you know maybe i'm making fun of
those parents because i i look at the
effort that they put in
um to try and find like uh
you know
the right food or whatever that you're
supposed to be feeding people i actually
follow this guy on um
on instagram
that has he has his own uh
he's got his own like he grows his own
food it's [ __ ] amazing
you mean he has a garden bill yeah i
couldn't sorry i'm searching for
something too
um
so uh i just realized something else you
know i was walking
when i was on the boardwalk there
in west palm beach
you know i had this playlist that i put
together this is like my gym music right
we are family by sister sledge kissing
my love bill withers
and then this guy that i just
discovered
through uh
fernando rosa base
is the count the account that i that i i
follow
and this guy just plays all of this
funk stuff like he did a judas priest
cover today he does a bunch of stuff but
he plays
this you know for a white dude like me
deep cut funk [ __ ] that i've never heard
of
and one of the guys he played
about a month and a month and a half ago
was this guy bernard wright
and i downloaded this album called nard
and i cannot recommend it highly enough
and it just blew my mind this guy's
playing all the instruments he's he's
like
just like a prodigy like he put this
album out i think he was like 17 or 18
years old
and i was listening to his music that
day and i got back to the hotel
and i saw quest love
had bernard wright rest in peace and i
was like oh my god why that because i
want to see him live in concert i guess
he died in an unfortunately in a some
sort of
traffic
auto accident
uh condolences out to him and his family
but um
i i mean
i couldn't believe it i just like so
weird there's just so many talented
people out there to find someone like
that he's so young i mean young to me
he was only 58 years old and you're
thinking you know
i bet this guy still kills it i can't
wait to go see him and all of this stuff
and uh so weird just just found out
literally found out about like four
weeks ago and now the guy's gone man
it's [ __ ] brutal don't mean to bum
you out but i was been meaning to tell
you about this album anyways check this
album out bernard wright nard
n-a-r-d um and just know he plays all
the instruments as far as i know i think
he plays all the instruments on the
album and there's a bunch of [ __ ]
that you'll hear um
you'll immediately recognize and a lot
of like the bridges and [ __ ] like that
that uh rappers have sampled and you
know turned into all these other great
songs and all of that [ __ ]
um
i guess snoop has sampled some of his
stuff like they were talking like in the
obituary um some of the
major rappers that have sampled his
stuff but jesus what a talent and what a
sad
sad thing and let's continue because
there's somebody i i've been meaning to
to talk about who passed away someone
closer to me in my life
was uh the great dick doherty
the godfather
the self-proclaimed
godfather
of the boston comedy scene
you know i don't know what his claim was
he wasn't a ding-ho guy
but i think that he was just like down
the cape
this renegade harley-driving
guy um
he had a great run he was 89 years old i
mean because i i knew i was like dude
that guy had to have been at least 90.
because he was like 60
in his 60s what
i started i guess he was like 59. [ __ ]
i'm almost as old as he was i'm gonna be
54 i'm five years away from how old dick
doherty was when i started oh my god
but um
rest in peace dick doherty i i had a
great relationship with him uh
throughout the years i still kept in
touch with him on um
social media and stuff facebook and that
type of stuff and he's just one of those
guys
you know
he gave me
i would say out of
a percentage
the percentage of stage time
say like you know my first two years in
comedy
i would say 65 to 70 percent of the
stage time was at a dick doherty room
somewhere and
this guy he was like the freddie
he was like jason a freddy krueger you
couldn't kill the guy and people for
years were predicting
he this is the you know because comedy
was in a bad place when i started the
the 80s boom was over and all of that
[ __ ] and this [ __ ] guy
would have like 10 rooms going
and then all of a sudden he'd lose one
he'd lose two and then all of a sudden
he'd lose four
and you just sit there thinking like
this guy's going under he's going under
and then he he'd come back with three
more
it was like a mickey ward arturo gotti
fight except it was dick doherty
versus uh i don't know what restaurant
owners
and um he had like his mainstays he had
this one
at a place used to uh be called
remingtons i believe emerson college
bought it
kind of buying up that whole area
um
and it used to be a bank and upstairs
there was a bar and downstairs was the
bank
the old like where the safe was so they
had this giant walk-in safe that they
just kept because what do you do throw
it out [ __ ] doorways like a zillion
pounds so they always work it into the
decor it was a really weird shape room
it was like an l-shaped room if the the
bottom part of the l was really short
uh and the rest of it was the green room
so you went into the green room which
was into a safe
and i remember you came down this ramp
it was a green rug this guy spiked tobin
hosted it
and that's the place where i put
together my first five minutes
and then i believe spike told dick doria
that i was funny and then i got to start
hosting and then he used to have these
these rooms
in chinese restaurants
the kuwaku's or the aku aku i don't know
how you said it um
the akuaku there was one in worcester
and then there was one in cambridge
and i remember uh
hosting there
he had a room in drake it he had one in
kenmore square
uh campus comedy i think he called in he
was trying to get people from b that one
didn't last too long drake it was a
[ __ ] nightmare that one didn't last
too long then he had him up in new
hampshire just had him [ __ ] all over
the place
and um that's the place where
really i put together one of those those
satellite rooms
i got good enough to start working for
mike clark at giggles in in uh
in the guys at knicks
and the comedy connection
uh bloomin rike and those guys so
it was a really like
important person
in the boston comedy scene that is
unfortunately passed away but he had a
great run 89 years old rest in peace
dick dougherty thank you so much
for all of the stage time i mean that
guy gave me hours and hours and hours
and hours and hours of stage time way
before i [ __ ] deserved it um
so uh there you go so there's there's
the in memorandum
part of the uh
the podcast that i'm assuming at this
point
it's time to do the reads i think
right 16 and seven 23 minutes i don't
think so
you know bill i don't really think so
how about the [ __ ] miami heat huh
they come out they win the first game
everybody's like yeah see they're the
number one seed they're not getting any
[ __ ] respect then they got their
asses
in game two
and then everybody's thinking ah here
comes the celtics and blah blah blah
blah and then they come out like [ __ ]
gangbusters i was working all i know is
they were down by like [ __ ] 24 27 or
something like that we cut it down to 10
and um
we couldn't get any closer but i heard
jimmy butler's hurt everybody's hurt
everybody's hurt man
um
except me
well emotionally maybe i'm hurt i don't
know
you know as always i should just [ __ ]
print out these goddamn things instead
of having to [ __ ] type the goddamn
password in
every [ __ ] time
you know what bill who gives a [ __ ]
exactly who gives a [ __ ] i'm on the
other side of mushrooms people i don't
flip out anymore
um
what else did i want to talk about oh
see west palm sweat celtics loose game
three trevor story
you know if the [ __ ] red sox could
just sign xander bogart's
and [ __ ] uh uh uh
rafael divers
i mean i think we might have the best
infield
in baseball
you know
our pitching's going to come around
avaldi what are you he's always throwing
for like seven innings
for the most part i think i think we'll
be all right oh do you bill
and what level did you play baseball at
i made it to the majors
in an instruction in a little league
i did i played i played one year of of
little league and then i made it to the
majors
in fifth grade
where you could steal bases which was
[ __ ] cool but then i got a d in math
and then that was it my parents were
just like your academics come first
[Music]
and then that was it
i was off the team and then
i never asked to play again because it
was just
too it was just you know what i mean
just too much
that's like i'm not going through that
[ __ ] [ __ ] again
you know i can get a d
i can keep getting d's in math
and not have to deal with
turning in a uniform and that's what i
did i cut out the turning in the uniform
part and i just continued to get d's in
math
and all of that [ __ ] i don't know
i always wondered what would happen if i
actually [ __ ]
i don't know was good at school
like where would i have been
yeah because you know you know what
there is there really is there's the you
that's born and then there's the [ __ ]
that happens to you and then you know
you spend the rest of your life trying
to figure out like
you know what would i have been
oh man that's an interesting movie
you know
i actually think sometimes
that when you actually work your way
back
to who you were supposed to be
you then die
isn't that weird like how many times you
sleep he had just gotten his life
together he was sober he was the
happiest he'd ever been right
he went deep sea fishing the hook caught
him in the seat of the pants and he
threw himself
overboard right in the mouth of a killer
whale
oh you should have seen the look on his
face he didn't even care
he was happy you know what you know what
hey hey hey
he figured it
and that's when everybody else goes he
figured it out and everybody does the
[ __ ]
yeah because he knows miserable
[ __ ] live forever [ __ ] live
forever it's almost like god's like
putting off seeing them
like all right i i know i i'll get to it
i'll get to it bring me a couple of
sweethearts all right i got a [ __ ]
headache today
you know
[Laughter]
like so many like musicians
comedians stevie ray vaughan
got sober put out his best [ __ ] album
and then we lose him sam kinnison was
sober
was on his way back
was going to get back to the sam
that he was when he first [ __ ] hit
and it was there's a
fan of stand up and i just started doing
stand-up and everything like that i
couldn't [ __ ] wait to see what that
guy was gonna talk about and he's taken
from us
you know what i mean
donald trump joe biden still [ __ ]
living still alive
still alive
trump's eating [ __ ] mcdonald's every
day [ __ ] dude won't die
all right
joe biden maybe yeah he probably had
mcdonald's he doesn't [ __ ] remember
um
i will be honest with you when i turned
on the tv i did see some news about
china
and taiwan and all of that [ __ ] and it's
jus it's just like what is going on
like i don't understand what is china
doing you got a huge piece of [ __ ]
land
you made it
nobody's knocking you off the block
there's a billion of you
you're good
what strategic [ __ ] horseshit
do you need
by going out there and grabbing that
island now i understand japan
they got a little strip of [ __ ] land
they're like england that's what
happened with england
bunch of pasty [ __ ]
[ __ ] elbow to elbow let's get some
boats and take some [ __ ] that's what
happens
i understand
uh
japan doing the same thing they had to
expand
they had to try to expand everybody else
is allowed to expand
do you know japan actually defeated
russia in a war
and when they went in to claim the land
like all the white countries do all the
other white countries got together and
said no you can't do that
and then they were like oh really
oh really
well here's pearl harbor for you
something like that i don't matter
i can't remember if i read that or if i
no i did read that i actually i used to
read people i used to have time to read
and uh things like that
i actually sat down and started i was
reading um
the [ __ ] i got a couple of just trashy
[ __ ] magazines
you know there's no mag you know what's
funny those are the only [ __ ]
magazines that seem to be left magazine
stands are gone and then just like the
just the
you know
um an older wiser who gives a [ __ ] talks
about how she finally figured it all out
whenever i see those articles i just
think to myself you didn't figure it all
out or god would have taken you you
would have been dead
you know
that's it you figure it out you get
happy then you die and then god's like
[ __ ] de niro come here you come here
you
okay you didn't rat out your friends you
didn't blame other people for your
problems you got sober and you figured
it out
all right
um
that's what god looks like in my world
he's like jimmy the gent minus the
murdering
although he does create murderess
doesn't he or is that the devil
um all right i think i've yammered
enough where i can do a little bit of
[ __ ] advertising here can i
can a bald orange man [ __ ] breed some
advertising when he wants to ladies and
gentlemen
oh [ __ ] i don't even have the [ __ ]
advertising i went right to the
questions
the question jerk
um
oh simply safe
i love these guys
simply safe everybody
that's what we all want to be
simple
and safe uh you guys you guys know i
love the break-in protection that my
simply safe home security system gives
me i absolutely do and what i love even
more is is you could literally shoot one
of those [ __ ] meerkat shows about the
amount of [ __ ] rodents
these goddamn raccoons at night coming
out there with their creepy hands
jumping up on my trash cans i had no
idea what the [ __ ] was going on out
there
um but as long as it's not a person
that's fine but if it is a person i'm
good because i have
simply safe
now a lot of people have a gun
on their nightstand i'm not one of those
guys i have like a kitchenaid
with that the pasta attachment and
that's what i'm coming at
you know
and i'm dropping it on your foot um
but it's not always outside forces that
you need simply safe's protection from
this is joshua's story a simply safe
customer from indiana
a few months ago
jesus they still telling this story i
want to hear another story a few months
ago he fell asleep with pizza rolls
still in the oven
[Music]
and a bunch of pre-rolls right next to
his [ __ ] hand uh this could have been
disastrous thousands of dollars in
damage to his kitchen and home or worse
luckily joshua has a comprehensive
simply safe system equipped with
everything to prevent break-ins and
smoke detectors to sniff out fires
he startled awake
um to the sound of a 95 decibel alarm
from his simply safe base station
i got the hiccups now
what did that mexican guy tell me to do
the home remedies
i already forget it was lime
you take a lime you put some [ __ ]
tabasco on it i don't forget
um
he startled away to the sound of a 95
decibel alarm from his simply safe base
station seconds later he got a call from
simply safe professional monitor hey you
[ __ ] pothead your pizza's on fire
thank you simply safe uh the pizza rolls
didn't make it but joshua did he
believes simply safe probably saved his
life that night
well i i think he could have gave it up
he saved his life if he was asleep and
there was a fire
in the structure he was in i would say
absolutely it did
are you being modest simply safe um
protecting people when their guard is
down is just one of the reasons more
than 4 million people use and love
simply safe with a comprehensive simply
safe system and 24 7 professional
monitoring you always have someone
looking out for you plus
oh plans cost under one dollar a day
with no long-term contracts or hidden
fees
ever
you can customize the perfect system for
your home in just a few minutes at
simplysafe.comburr
go today and claim a free indoor
security camera plus twenty percent off
with interactive monitoring go to
simplysafe.com that's
[Music]
dot
s-i-m-p-l-i-s-a-f-e.com
uh sorry oh look who it is everybody
look who it is
our old friend's old zip
[Music]
zip recruiter everybody you know certain
people just make my life so much easier
i don't know what i do without them
talk about a person or people you rely
on to help you out with certain things
you know what my kids make my life easy
i come home dad dad dad they make me
feel loved
they come up they give me hugs
and then they jump on me and [ __ ]
drop elbows and stuff and i think it's
hilarious and then i take them for a
ride my own my old truck
it's fun
um examples a family member or a friend
i just did that
your partner
i am not in a gay relationship your
co-host i don't have a co-host your
personal assistant
your podcast producer you know andrew
themeless
i mean
not only does he pick out good music
every it's obscure music
he introduces you to new bands
i don't know what i do without him
it's been working for me forever
um crushing it uh it's like you own a
grow it's like if you own a growing
business and need to hire
zip
recruiter
uh zip recruiter makes hiring so much
easier because they do the work for you
and right now you can try it for free at
zip
dot com slash burst zipper crew uses its
powerful technology that's powerful
technology to find and match the right
candidate up with your job you can
easily rev review these recommended
candidates and invite your top choices
to apply
additionally zip
recruiter
it's an old car has a complete
suite
of tools that make it easy to filter
review and rate your candidates
four to five
who post on zip
[Music]
that was me falling off a cliff before i
could finish saying it get a quality
candidate within the first day no wonder
ziprecruiter is the number one rated
hiring site based on g2 satisfaction
ratings as of january 1st 2022
in fact the hardest thing you have to do
uh is to remember our special url
ziprecruiter.com
burr that's where you go
uh to try zip
for free once again that's
ziprecruiter.com spell out bird b-u-r-r
zip recruiter the smartest way
to hire
all right well speaking of the smartest
way to do things i'm gonna mosey on over
here and get myself a liquid death
boy oh boy do i love a liquid death what
do i like about a liquid death well i'll
tell you
what would you rather do
would you rather drink beer out of a can
or would you want to drink it out of a
plastic [ __ ] bottle
why have we been drinking water out of
plastic bottles for all of these [ __ ]
years because that's how it started
and we never knew there was a better way
it's like how america is slowly
discovering a bidet
all of these years are using toilet
paper
when you could really just have your
[ __ ] [ __ ] sprayed down
like it showed up at a protest
sorry it's delicious
[Music]
ah
i love it
um
god damn it that's good [ __ ] water
all right you know what i actually found
that i haven't played in a while here
where the [ __ ] is it you [ __ ]
remember this one
come on
come
on does that not work anymore
hey
that's
melody somebody else
how are you
you know each week you guys write in
you know why do you write in
because you don't have someone special
in your life
you can't afford therapy i don't know
what it is or maybe you just like
hearing how stupid i am
people write in all the time
they ask me questions they ask for
advice i don't know why i don't have any
sort of training
i don't have a degree in anything
you guys ask me questions you tell me
about stuff you tell me i don't know
what the [ __ ] i'm talking about
dude i'm telling you right now the
screensaver on my this new computer
screen i don't know what this is
this is like if i was on acid and i was
looking at a porcupine
and the sun was going down really fast
does that make any sense
it's like if i was really close to the
thing
no i'm not on drugs right now but it's
just
it's mesmerizing um all right question
hey billy boy
funny enough the song you sang a snippet
of is called billy boy
miles davis is the only person in
history who could make it cool and he
did a hip coverage of it on his album
milestones
um listen to philly joe jones just play
the [ __ ] out of those drums oh that yeah
tell me where have you been billy boy
billy boy tell me where have you been
charming billy
he's a young kid that wants to go with
scouting like a scout he's a young kid
that wants to go with scouting
and just when you think that horrible
song's over there's a second we can't
can you scramble me an egg billy boy
billy boy can you scramble me an egg
charming billy i [ __ ] hated that song
when i was a kid
kids used to just [ __ ] sing you know
it's weird that that was enough to set
you off
you know especially if you know you if
you were left-handed and had red hair
and you were basically the devil spawn
[ __ ] ginger that i was um
that was enough to set you off when you
were a little kid if somebody if they
older bigger kids started singing a song
that had your name in it
probably because it said charming
because the big kids were can you
scramble me an egg charming billy i'd be
like stop singing that song
and they're like all right entertainment
let's get this [ __ ] freckled [ __ ]
going right
um
what was another one billy don't be a
hero don't be a fool with your life
they would sing that
walking through the woods
it's like can you guys just get to
beating the [ __ ] out of me can you
please stop with the [ __ ] billy
karaoke
um so miles davis did a hip version of
it
um anyway hey years but years ago this
person continues before therapy i sent a
really stupid email to you which you
referenced on the show i was ticked at
the time but i feel a pang of
embarrassment regret whatever whenever
it crosses my mind hey you're forgiven
you're forgiven i don't care we all get
like that no problem okay
and if i read your email today i still
wouldn't have a problem with it because
i know it would have nothing to do with
me
something happened to you and you're
working it out all right i'm working out
my [ __ ] you're working out your [ __ ]
i hope chyna can work out their [ __ ]
with america we don't [ __ ] kill a
bunch of innocent people
on both sides
why don't these suited [ __ ] [ __ ]
relax
um anyway not that it matters but sorry
man i'm glad you talk about therapy
maybe if men keep going we can all have
less stupid [ __ ] to deal with in this
world go [ __ ] yourself to philly joe
jones
unachievable perfection
that's funny um yeah
yeah if i i i don't like uh i don't i
don't [ __ ] carry [ __ ] anymore it's
[ __ ] great
it's [ __ ] great it's a great it's a
great [ __ ] place to be
um and you could do it too if i did it
german irish [ __ ] lunatic you could
do it too um
yeah i got this new thing man
when i with when i meet people or
whatever
um
i finally i used to like when i used to
meet psychos
you know i grew up with psychos and i
was like i don't want to i don't want to
be with like psychos anymore
you know when i when i grow up you know
i'm going to have a psycho free [ __ ]
life no lunatics right
and then you go out in the world and you
meet lunatics and it feels like home
you're like oh i i relate to this this
feels like my hometown this feels like
the way i grew up
and then you end up recreating the [ __ ]
and then you end up doing the [ __ ] you
didn't want to be doing right
so now that i'm on the other side of
that now i can kind of like i don't know
when you get older you can kind of fast
forward through relationships so now
this is my [ __ ]
if i talk to somebody have a meeting
with somebody business [ __ ] whatever
or maybe i'm you know meet somebody
maybe we're going to start hanging out
if after i hang out with them or talk to
them on the phone or or
email exchange
if i have to unpack [ __ ]
if i'm walking around talking to myself
going i should have said this when they
said that yeah [ __ ] that person
you know business is one thing though
you know business it's like you kind of
have to like
you can't just you know
business is a weird world you know you
kind of have to put up with a certain
degree of [ __ ] but just in general
um i find myself now i start to get
angry and then i go whoa whoa whoa whoa
wait wait wait wait
[ __ ] this person
out of my life
that's the way uh-huh uh-huh i like it
uh-huh oh that's it out
out the door
then i put on a polyester shirt and i
[ __ ] dance like that guy an airplane
to disco and have a great night
um that's my new thing it's been working
out for me
anyway i think bill burr saved my life
at the hollywood bowl
what are you talking about i did like
seven minutes and i left
hi bill
bill oh hi bill
recruiter burr
i flew over from la from australia and
the day we arrived was dave chappelle
and friends at the hollywood bowl
i'm never gonna forget that i am never
gonna forget
thank you to dave chappelle if i didn't
say it already i know i said it to him
directly but jesus christ i have to say
it on the podcast like i will never
[ __ ] forget
the level of artists that i've seen on
that [ __ ] stage to be standing there
was just
surreal anyway before jumping in the
uber to the go to the bowl i ate one
gummy just one
well that all depends on how many
milligrams it was uh night was going
well felt a little buzzed my girlfriend
now fiance congratulations and i found
our seats and started to enjoy jeff ross
doing his thing everything was going
well until the sun went down
the gummy is obviously nocturnal and
this is hi and his little demon ass woke
the [ __ ] up oh boy
feeling overwhelmed with paranoia you
can't you can't give in to it man you
got to ride it out
you got to write it out and just be like
of course i'm paranoid i ate marijuana
that's it
that's what this is there's nothing
really to fear here
okay someone you know
other than the lunatic who charged the
stage all right i'm gonna continue ask i
asked my girlfriend to get me a coke and
a water big mistake she must have been
gone for 10 minutes and boy oh boy did
it feel like an hour to me oh my god
dude you didn't eat a gummy you ate
gummies or you ate something that was
like in the 30 to 50 range
i would guess i started to panic
thinking something has happened to her
i ran to the drink lines and could not
find her oh dude are you new to this
[ __ ]
just sit there and laugh about how
scared you are
whenever i would get like that i just
would just i would think a [ __ ]
shaggy on scooby-doo
and i i i like when he he wouldn't say
whoa
he'd say like before it like whoa that's
what i would think when i would start
freaking out
if i ate something and i and and i
thought
i had reached the top floor only to
realize that i was only halfway up
that's what i would always do to keep
myself calm i would just think of shaggy
and i would just go like
[Music]
it would just make me laugh
and i'm like all right
because it's really not about how high
you're gonna go it's it's it's really
about
you need to feel that initial descent
and you're like all right i survived
i made it all the way to the top and now
we're going back down again even if
you're a thousand [ __ ] feet in the
air
you know you know that now you're at 980
and you survived a thousand and then
you're fine so i it's it's the way up
that's [ __ ] scary i find
um anyway
i said she must been gone for 10 minutes
and boy oh boy did it feel like an hour
to me i started panicking
i started panicking thinking something
has happened to her so i ran to the
drink lines and could not find her i ran
to the security and got them all looking
for her i was convinced something had
happened to her
after causing such a ruckus i returned
to my seat to find her sitting there
shaking her head
oh god i've been there
by the time i explained the shenanigans
to my girl
my girlfriend they began to announce the
next guest you
seeing the moon man head straight
[Music]
strut across the stage brought me such
joy and excitement and took me right out
of the paranoid state i was in turned
out to be the greatest night
of the trip
meaning the vacation uh second to
proposing to my fiance at disneyland
good for you
uh what ride were you on uh close second
um
oh
thanks for saving the day and go [ __ ]
yourself oh all right man i've been
there
i bet that happened to me earlier this
year i i thought i was taking 10 which i
can handle and i accidentally you know
i didn't talk to the person who gave
them to me and i i think i think i had
at least 40 if not 50
and i was sitting i was in a chair that
i wanted to get up
out of for two hours and just could not
figure out how to do it if i just stood
up it would have been fine but i was
just like
my head felt like a magnet
you know what i mean when there's
another magnet close by
and they're opposite or the same charge
so they're like pushing each other away
that's what that felt like that was
inside my head
um
that's a pretty good description i would
say all right ufo talk oh i love this
[ __ ]
i'd love to meet an alien
and just be like what the [ __ ] why the
[ __ ] would you come here
you missed it man
you should have been here a couple
hundred years ago before we [ __ ] this
whole thing up
you needed to get here before plastic
and nuclear weapons in the gas
combustion engine
that's when you should have came here i
don't know what to tell you before white
people came out of this side of the
[ __ ] world that's
when you needed
to get here you missed it you missed the
boat wait what do you want here huh
you're gonna take over the planet
what are you gonna do next buy a vcr
this place is uh
it's over
um bill you ever get the feeling that
all these open government hearings about
ufos is a bit suspect
why are they all of a sudden asking
questions out in the open about this
they denied everything but the moon's
existence but now they want an open
conversation about this it's a huge leap
i tend to believe the theory that they
want us to think new hypersonic planes
are really alien ships
so that they don't have to share the
technology with us
well wait a minute
every military plane for the most part
other than a cargo plane flies faster
than they have all kinds of [ __ ] in the
military they're not going to share with
us
why should they share it with us
where the [ __ ] do you have to go in
hypersonic speed
look how fast covid spread you want to
be hypersonic after you [ __ ] jerk off
a bat and [ __ ] a monkey whatever the
[ __ ] these things come from there's
always some there's always somebody
doing something with an answer they went
from the [ __ ] animals
jesus christ
what's wrong with people
um i tend to believe the theory okay all
right uh they want to keep the new
hypersonic planes no they're already
advertising those things
what [ __ ] over supersonic travel
unfortunately
was that was the uh the concord crashing
i think
but that was around for like 20 years
and nobody else jumped on it
but that was always a dream of mine i
always wanted to fly that thing from new
york
over to paris in like [ __ ] three
hours whatever it did it just seemed
[ __ ]
incredible um
but no that shit's coming
i think that they're gonna have [ __ ]
electric ones if we survive i think
they're gonna have like
you know the electric ones and uh
but the thing what we have to do is we
have to [ __ ] recycle we never [ __ ]
recycle like all of these goddamn
batteries that they're gonna put in
these things now you know god damn well
with you know all of the carbon
footprint of all this [ __ ] you have to
get
right what the [ __ ] what the what are
all bathroom lithium is that what that's
all made of then i heard china like
bought up all the [ __ ]
mines see this is what happens you get a
little bit of information oh that's why
we're saying china's doing something
because we want to get the lithium back
from them and and there's hypersonic
planes this is why i tapped out from all
of this [ __ ]
and i'm watching baseball this early i'm
telling you people don't worry about
[ __ ] that's bigger than your pay grade
all right get yourself a habit
coffee cigars all of the above drinking
whatever the [ __ ] you're into
pick a team and just follow them
and let these [ __ ] [ __ ]
i don't know what i
i can't deal with it anymore anyway i'm
getting okay i'm bumming you guys out
i'm sorry it's already confirmed
other countries have hypersonic weapons
hypersonic weapons you went from planes
so on these hypersonic planes they have
weapons on them what's a hyper sonic
sonic weapon
how much faster can the missile get here
i can't imagine uncle sam not being in
the same business
all paid for by suckers like us who will
never get to ride past jupiter or mars
in other words
thanks for the left
i have for the [ __ ] life of me i have
no idea why anybody wants to go to mars
why would you want to do like
that is just the ultimate cross-country
[ __ ] flight i will tell you this too
right now
i understand wanting to go into outer
space
all right and then come back
okay the bottom line is
it's all about
coming back
and te and talking loud about it and
they're beautiful women so maybe one of
them will [ __ ] you
how are you gonna do that if you're
going all the way out to like i don't
know where you guys how [ __ ] cold
it's gonna be out there
on mars
i don't know
you know let's let's you know i'm gonna
look up mars forecast let's see what
they say
let me see here
planet
mars
fork it doesn't even come up forecast
planet mars national weather surface
temperatures on mars average minus 81
degrees
fahrenheit
you know what's [ __ ] funny a green
bay packer game the right time of year
is actually colder than that can be uh
maybe not uh however temperatures range
from around 200 minus 220 degrees
fahrenheit in the winter time
at the poles
to
70 degrees fahrenheit well that's when
you want to go
oh my god we want a trip to mars but
it's in the winter
oh
i went there my nose fell off
so of course it wasn't covered
you know and like delta wouldn't let me
board and i was like you're letting all
these other people board before group
one i lost my nose on this trip and they
said we're sorry there's nothing we can
do about it
um
they can keep their hypersonic travel i
don't give a [ __ ]
they can have underground tunnels
they can put [ __ ] you know elk heads
on and [ __ ] each other i don't give a
[ __ ] what they do as long as i can just
sit on my back porch and nobody [ __ ]
with me and i can just look at the
little piece of [ __ ] land that i that
they let me have
until they decide it's not mine anymore
as long as i can do that i'm good
then all i need is just the sports
packages by the way and i i want to
apologize to the race fans uh who feel
neglected on this i am so [ __ ] far
behind in f1 and mo i don't even know
what's going on in motogp last i looked
in f1
ferrari was winning
mercedes was trying to figure it out and
red bull finally got their act together
i missed the miami race and i missed the
one that happened
i believe today
uh my wife deleted one of them and then
i think she [ __ ] up the recording on
it and i'm
doing a bunch of [ __ ] and i know i'm i'm
missing the season i wanted to see
which is ferrari came back
and then
lewis hamilton's having a problem which
if you're a fan of racing that's what
the [ __ ] you that's the scenario you
want cause now you're gonna see some
racing if lewis hamilton's not having a
[ __ ] problem from the jump you know i
mean last year was great and everything
like that but i didn't like how it ended
you know
that [ __ ] restart and everything that
was [ __ ] um
although
i you know and he handled it like a
[ __ ] man so what are you gonna do but
i i like watching that guy having to
play catch up i like watching
mercedes have to [ __ ] catch up
because if they're out in the if they're
if you know they're out there in the
clean air the whole thing's over i know
bill you say this every time you bring
it up okay all right
all right all right home remedy remedy i
need a remedy remedy banana peel to
treat warts
hey billy gingersnap ladylistener
here from billings montana ah man i
haven't been up there i don't think i've
ever been there i went to hastings that
was nebraska
did i go to helena maybe i went to
billings
i can't remember anyway my grandmother
and mom have a home remedy for treating
warts rub the inner surface of a ripe
banana peel on the wart and then bury
the banana peel in the backyard
what
burying the peel in the backyard seems a
bit witch doctory all right thank you
we're on the same page again but i can
say i've tried the remedy and it does
work
love the podcast come to montana what
the
that's somebody just [ __ ] with me i
mean what is burying it what does that
do
what the [ __ ] would
i would think at some point that that
would then affect
the banana the banana would have warts i
don't i don't underst
all right i'm not doing that all right
i'm not you know what i'm not playing i
you know what i have too much to unpack
on that i'm done with you i'm walking
away
see that i'm mature
all right that is the podcast everybody
let's go celtics let's go red sox
that's all we got going on no more
bruins god damn it um i watched a little
bit of calgary
versus edmonton i didn't know they had
evander kane
i'm just [ __ ] out of the loop
remember how on it i used to be not
saying i used to pick the games but i
[ __ ] knew who was playing i don't
know [ __ ] anymore
oh brother um
whatever who gives a [ __ ] this is the
podcast i had fun i hope you had fun
all right
i'm telling you man try that if [ __ ]
people are if they're a lot if
somebody's a [ __ ] lot
if somebody in your life calls and you
look down and you see their [ __ ]
number you just see their phone number
and you're just like oh my god hey don't
pick up
don't pick up
all right
just let them fade away
or you can just have a conversation with
them just being like yeah you know it's
just uh
you know my friends are easy we hang out
we have a good time we laugh and
afterwards i'm glad it happened
i don't walk around in my pajamas at
three in the morning later on talking
about it all right that's it go [ __ ]
yourselves and i'll check in on you on
thursday
now how do i shut this thing off this is
my newfangled thing this is the this is
the bonus
part of this [ __ ] podcast i don't
know how to shut this off i guess maybe
i could edit it out
edit it out
okay and then oh you [ __ ] [ __ ]
all right
why does it keep doing this [ __ ] why oh
why won't you [ __ ] work for me
oh it's a wireless keyboard man it's not
tethered to nothing man
so now what do i do
oh i have to go with the mouse
the mouse
the mouse
okay
then i do this
and then for some reason like 20 [ __ ]
letters come in
all right all right all right
all right
there we go
[ __ ] you you [ __ ]
oh you f f
[ __ ] [ __ ]
why why a wireless [ __ ]
why would you go wireless
i'm not gonna lie this is embarrassing
this [ __ ] keyboard it's [ __ ]
wireless and just doesn't work it just
doesn't work
you know what i'll figure it out
i'll figure it out
and then everything will be fine